[Music]  I was hoping through the art piece to  show different facets of Arab culture  including calligraphy as well as the  history of the world cup from its  Inception until now  foreign  [Music]  was  1595.76 square meters they achieved the  record the artist Ahmed Salah achieved  the record of 9652 so this is six times  the size of the previous record so it's  a quite an impressive record  [Music]  when the world sees this art piece which  is the largest in the world they will be  able to see our heritage they will see  how we are able to combine culture art  and sports and at the same time we are  able to achieve great things at a global  level  [Music]  [Applause]